hey little guys my name is Regina
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we took a look at creating
Windows and we used to shell fw to
actually create the window for our game
engine and we talked a lot about
abstractions and how we can actually
abstract that window kind of logic API
outside of just sticking to a singular
platform because obviously Hazel's gonna
be spotting multiple platforms so
definitely check out that video if you
haven't already because that's gonna be
vital for this video in which we're
going to actually add events through
that window
so windows right windows generates
nature they generate events so anytime
we move the mouse we press a key we
close the window we resize the window we
click a mouse button all of that
generates something called an event if
you guys haven't seen the events video
where we actually implemented both the
event system but also the video before
that where we planned it definitely
check it out in fact check out the whole
game engine series playlist it's really
important that you guys kind of watch
all the videos in order because they
helped shed a lot of light as to what
we're actually doing in any given
episode anyway the point is that in
those videos we kind of setup everything
that we need to both create an event
right and have some kind of event
framework which delivers events through
specific parts of our code base and then
we also create the winter wishes capable
of generating news events so what we
need to do now is kind of link those two
systems together and that's really what
this video is going to be about we need
to be able to say that hey whatever an
event occurs inside our window right we
want to kind of create one of our events
and dispatch it and kind of throw it out
into the world and then whatever inside
our engine or later inside our game or
application that actually wants to
handle a certain type of event can and a
really good example really simple good
example right now that we actually
desperately kind of need is the close
button so when we hit the close button
in hazel right now in a hazel
application nothing happens it just we
click it and nothing happens well we
actually want to happen is we want to
terminate the program right so that's
what we're going to kind of implement
today as well as just being able to
dispatch all the different event types
like key presses Mouse events window
resized events all that kind of stuff
take a look and how we can actually set
that up so let's just go ahead and do it
okay so our actual application class is
kind of bland right now not much going
on here but what we actually need to do
is to be able to set a callback function
on the window so inside window what we
actually made was something called set
event callback right and this is
something that comes from the abstract
window of course and the event callback
function is basically just a function
which returns void and takes in an event
reference as as as its parameter we need
to be able to set that up so that when
we actually call our events when we
generate events over here we dispatch
them to that callback function so to do
that we'll just set the callback we'll
just set the event callback and we
actually need to bind it to one of the
functions in here or at least that's
what I want to do we could just use a
lambda or something like that but I'm
going to bind it to an actual real
function so I'm going to have a function
here called an event which takes in just
an event as an argument like that I'm
gonna go ahead and copy that and then
implement it over here so there we go
and then this is this come we can
actually use the event dispatcher that
we created which is located over here to
then kind of dispatch the appropriate
event to the appropriate method or
function that we actually have here and
we'll take a look at that in a minute so
we'll set the event callback to actually
be this specific event and the way we
can do that just by using standard bind
will bind application event you could
create a macro for this I usually end up
doing that um I'm sorry on event that
ends up making things easier especially
with this whole placeholders thing but
you know I think is probably fine I'll
show you what I mean anyway so might as
well do it you know bind event function
or something
just become something like something
like we just wrote except we can just
take an X here and so this this line of
code becomes by an event function on
event and that's it obviously something
like this only works in the context of
this class but you couldn't you can
actually take this whole thing out if
you want
and then this would just be application
on event which might be even nicer so
just something to consider
anyway I'm going to just go back to this
okay cool so we've set up the event
callback the event callback goes into
this window data structure we have here
so if we call a van callback now that
we've kind of set it up it's actually
going to end up calling this on event
function for now let's just go ahead and
print it so I'll do age said in 4h that
core in for 8 okay and then I'll rather
we have to provide formatting string so
we'll do that and then 8 so I just
printing the event and because we have a
two string implemented on every event it
should just print some nice details
about what kind of event it is and what
the data is set to okay great so now
let's actually set up the events so I'll
write a nice comment here it basically
just says set your W callbacks because
we're going to grab some callbacks from
gel W as I just said the month so we'll
do the window size callback first so we
need to pass in the window and then a
function that actually will get called
whenever the window size changes so for
this all we really need to do is I'm
just gonna use a lambda like create a
lambda which takes in a gel W window and
then I think the best way to really do
this is just to go to the callback
function and just to go through this
actual window size fun and see what
actually is so you can see um it's the
window point and then three integers and
these two integers are the width and
height so we know that it's the window
window and then the width and then I and
then we can have the actual
implementation written here so how do we
now inside this lambda end up calling
this application functioning and and
also creating the right event that's
kind of the the mace of this function so
first of all you might recall that we
said a window user pointer what this
means is that onto this winter kind of
gel W window is this kind of struct here
that is defined somewhere and that has a
basically like a spot for us to put any
we want in the form of this window user
pointer right so it's just a void point
that can be pointed to anything we've
set it to be a pointer to this data
structure that we have here which
contains all this data so basically what
that means is that inside this function
since we have access to gel W window we
can just kind of get the user point of
get window user point on from the window
right that returns a void pointer so now
we need to cast this to be the correct
type which for us is window data because
that's what we've set the user point it
to be so we just need to do window data
reference data equals window to line up
and then we're just dereferencing in
here okay there we go and then we
actually need to make the hazel event so
we right window resize events event and
then I think we just need to take it and
be looking higher and that's it no need
to include all of these events or events
application event all we need all them
anyway so might as well flip it now
Mouse event and gonna okay cool so there
we go
so we've made that now we can dispatch
it by just doing data event callback
with the event but then we also have
inside our data a width and height that
is maintained accounted by the window
right so we also need to set that up so
we'll say dot a dot width equals wit and
died at the higher angles like cool so
we've created a window resize event
we've dispatched it I mean then we've
done all this I might actually do this
first just so that we basically even
before we create any kind of event stuff
the window already has the updated size
because just hypothetically speaking if
inside one of these event kind of
handling functions we decide to query
the window for its width and height it
would be wrong because it hasn't updated
yet so this way it's just a little bit
better okay and that's it and you can
say this kind of the same pattern that
we have here is just repeated for every
kind of event
so of cfw said winter close call back as
well just becomes I think this is quite
simple I think this is just a winter
pointer and not say it and then if this
happens it will copy this line I all we
need to really do is create that window
close event and then dispatch it so your
daughter event callback and then and
that's it
so next one I probably doesn't really
just copy it next one will do is the key
callback so we'll set the key callback
to be in window and then the callback
function which we probably need to copy
so again we'll go into here I'll go to
the key function and then we have window
and then for integers so case calculate
action mods so hey Stanford action mods
and then again we'll drop this window
data now what we need to do at some
point by the way is because this key
code is kind of jail I'll be specific we
need to convert it into a Hazel key code
because on other platforms where we
don't use gel W we don't we don't want
to be tied to those kind of key codes we
want to have our own so at some point we
need to do some kind of conversion so
this one's gonna be a little bit more
complicated and the other ones we
basically want to switch on the action
because GL value provides us with a
bunch of different actions there's main
cold press there's something called
release and then there's something
called repeat as well so press release
repeat in the case of press and we'll
pull we have to surround this in
brackets as well
bunch of variables with the same name so
a key pressed event gets credit here and
then the key is what we pass in as well
as a repeat count of zero so the key
being the key card of the key that was
pressed and then we'll just call the
event callback that repeat is going to
be the same except djellaba does
actually provide us with a repeat count
even though the win32 api can do that so
we'll just add this to one for now if we
want that in the future it's possible to
extract so we'll kind of keep that in
mind and then release is just key
release event and then mobster don't
have a repeat now for that okay there we
go that is what we need to do I like to
indent this though just so it's a bit
more clear so we'll do that and there we
go
cool and that's all we need to do for
the key for the key callbacks so the
next one will move on through is the
mouse button pull back this is basically
the same as a cake ball back except the
mouse buttons so I think this one yeah
just has three integers so the button
the action and then the mods action box
so we will grab this again you guys kind
of see how maybe why I like um to
actually have the code written
beforehand and then just kind of show
you the diff because I think it's a
little bit less time waste II but anyway
for this video I thought I'd type it out
because it's not that much code so we'll
switch on the action
and again mouse presses and releases it
handles the same way so we have the
press event and the release event we
don't have a repeat offense a so mouse
button pressed event so at the button
that was pressed is really all we need
and the event callback mouse mass
released event same thing except this is
a lot of still enrollees and that is it
for mouse buttons and then we have two
more we have the mouse position and the
mouse scroll as well do the mouse scroll
first so set mouse scroll what is it
so it's ball callback this just has two
doubles yep such a double which is the X
offset and the y offset of the scroll so
it's X offset and also it doubles okay
and then we grab this again oops and
then we make a mouse scrolled event cost
a sports
and then dispatched it okay and then
finally we have our as a position
sprawled call back scroll back up and
say and then that of course is just
whatever the mass moves we can get a
call back with the position of lightness
now so this is just X position and y
position and I think they would doubles
actually why they yeah they were doubles
I guess we have two doubles um we can I
think we just have them as either cancel
floats which should be fine so it has a
position of pullback
x position Y position wrap this again
and then this is just a mouse raised
event event we actually have you get two
flights so will cost them to float as we
did with the scrolling and then we're
told we'll just call this and that's it
that's all of our events implemented so
now one more thing that I actually want
to add is a GLW error callback so what
we could the other kind of type of
callback that GL w actually does and i
think we'll do this inside here i miss
it as we initialize GL videos we can
actually set an error callback and i'll
set this to be like an actual kind of
function so we'll just call it built
over the error callback and we'll make
this function up here just be a section
for now but this is just going to be w
arrow pull back
I think the error callback function
takes in an Internet culture so the
error and then a description so we'll
pop that in here
our description and then all will do for
now is just log it
so we'll say ash that Correira jelf w
era and then I think then put this in
brackets is that's the error code and
then we'll put the description a sort of
arrow and then the description
okay so we've now got an error callback
as well okay
anyway that is done that is everything
that we need to do here so now what we
should be able to do is just kind of run
this and we should back an application
get every single event being logged so
let's go ahead and try that okay so here
is the engine and then here we have our
log kind of catalog here you can see
that when we move the mouse we get the
position of the mouse when we click we
get button press and released event and
depending on which button is pressed as
well if I type let me get key release if
I hold down the thing we it's as you can
see the repeat is set to one and then
what else can either scroll resize the
window you can see how that works as
well it's quite nice
and then for close we should get a
closed event and you can see we do says
a window close okay cool so now let's
implement that closed event and also
show you guys have a dispatcher works
because I think there were quite a few
questions on how to actually use the
event dispatcher and it's very very easy
so over here we'll stop logging all of
our events I'm actually well could I
keep that in there just for debug
purposes for this build I guess I think
we're doing it yeah it's in for maybe
let's do it as trace no it's not grain
and then we'll just do event dispatcher
dispatcher we passed in the event now we
know that for a window closed event what
we actually want is and all kind of
probably write this down here what we
actually want for window closed event is
just a bull on window
closed and then window closed event I
guess I'll call it winter clothes winter
clothes event eight that is basically
the signature of kind of an event
function right we'll go ahead and
implement it full application on window
closed closed event I might actually
move this to below run because probably
want to see run more than we do want us
and then we actually wanna see that
and then this will return true I guess
that's been handled
but basically we'll just setting it to
false and that should obviously
terminate this loop at the next point
that this is queried rather it will see
that it's false terminate the loop and
then that way we have nothing else to
run in our application edge and it
should close so to dispatch that all we
need to do is say that hey dispatch show
so we've created a dispatcher now we
just say dispatch show if you see a
window close event right then dispatch
it to this function now we can use this
bind event function we had before to
bind a function to this you could just
create a lambda like I did with the
other stuff that's totally fine
usually though you probably want to
actually have a function so we'll do
bind event function and then on winter
clothes and obviously we're already in
the inside the application airspace
because it's in the macro that's it
that's all you have to do so what will
happen here is that if this event that
comes through is a window close event
right and it does start by checking the
type over here it checks to see if the
event type of the incoming event is
equal to the static type of the template
that you used here right which you can
do by just calling you know T which in
this case is window closed event get
static type because you can see that um
obviously the window closed event
implements event class type which
implements get static type as the type
of window closed right so if that comes
in that then it actually will call this
function which in this case is this and
it's that running to false so let's hit
f5 and see what happens okay so we got a
bunch of errors and probably just
because of not including stuff so we
have up occasionally included here I
might move that to here
because it doesn't know what we're no
closer ven is let's hit f5 and hopefully
it'll work okay
there we go so we have all the mouse
move events sit down everything is kind
of tracing in the non green thing which
is good and now if I hit close there
your application closes so that is how
we implement events and this will be the
basis for pretty much the events for the
rest of the engine so once we have
layers and more of a better system for
that then the application will be in
charge of actually dispatching those
events further down because now the
application while having no knowledge at
all of gfw or of our window right well I
mean window doesn't have any knowledge
of application we just get a nice little
callback with just the event which is
nice and clean and pretty cool all right
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did you can hit the like button leave
any comments below as to what you think
of this whole event system because now
we've kind of come to the conclusion I
guess of implementing it
we had the planning stage we had the
implementation stage and now we kind of
have connected visited to jail W to our
windows to our window and we have kind
of the entire picture now of events in
hazel so let me know what you think this
kind of taught you something cool I
think that this is quite a nice clean
event system I always love or any things
like this and really it is the basis for
everything else because now if we decide
that we want like a 3d camera or
whatever in our scene we won't have to
like be like oh but I don't have these
certain events as I mentioned with input
there we do still need to implement some
kind of polling system where we can
actually ask for the current state of
things we can't do that right now
without using the GLB api so definitely
we need to get off to that and then
there's also a huge list of things that
I really want to do like right now so
next video is going to be a bit of a
surprise I think you guys want to
support this series you can go to
patreon.com/scishow no huge thank you as
always to everyone who supports that
series next video for you guys of course
is available as always there'll be a
link in this video comments below you'll
get access to software that's way ahead
of this because I developed hazel on a
private branch which I also used to kind
of plan these videos and in that branch
I kind of just deal with it as fast as I
can so whenever I have free time or
whatever I can just write some code
and so we've got like you know we've got
like I'm gooey in there we've got OpenGL
rendering we've got like it's way
advanced so definitely check that out if
you interested anyway I hope you guys do
this video again and I'll see you next
time goodbye
[Music]